يرتبط الشعور بالسعاده بعد مشاهده الاعمال
الفنيه القديمه بعده اسباب تكون معا عوامل
الشعور بالسعاده اولها عدم وجود عنصر
مفاجاه فمعرفه الاحداث يجلب لك شعورا
بالارتياح مع الانتباه للتفاصيل الصغيره
التي قد تكون لم تلاحظها من قبل بالاضافه
الى الحنين لاوقات مميزه في حياتنا خاصه
تلك المرتبطه بتذكر وقت محدد في حياتنا
وبعد الاعمال القديمه تعيدون الى فتره
الطفوله او الحب الاول ذلك الرابط القوي
مع صديق قديم ربما شاهدتم نفس العمل سويا
وعندما نشاهد العروض او الافلام القديمه
فاننا بالفعل نعرف الاحداث لذا يمكن
متابعتها بسهوله دون الحاجه الى التركيز
او بذل كثير من الجهد المعرفي لمعالجه
الاحداث وتحليلها اعاده مشاهده عمل فني مع
ارتباطك بالشخصيات يعيد اليك مشاعر محببه
كرؤيه صديق قديم فالمشاعر التي تثيرها
الشخصيات المالوفه تشعر المشاهد بالدعم
والراحه كما ان بعض الذكريات تلهمنا
للتواصل مره اخرى مع الاصدقاء القدامى
التي ربما انقطعنا عن التواصل معهم ما
يزيد من الترابط الاجتماعي